on va tester un truc de fou aujourd'hui
un truc de fou grâce à ce monsieur là
qui étaient avec moi sachez que cette
vidéo ne serait pas possible sans
emmanuel pampuri je vais vous en parler
un petit peu plus après dans la vidéo
mais on va tester vous l'aurez deviné la
cs3 we will hassett s3 celui que tout le
monde attend mais on testera on testera
juste après l'intro
[Musique]
et salue les gens n'allaient quand c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mon
corps je suis ravi de vous retrouver
comme à chaque fois pour une nouvelle
vidéo aujourd'hui vraiment une vidéo je
me sens hyper privilégié merci manu
emmanuel temps puristes si vous le
connaissez pas ce mec c'est il a un cv
long comme le bras en terme de vidéo
il a une chaîne youtube je vous mets le
lien dans la description c'est un tueur
c'est un tueur et il m'a amené
aujourd'hui le sony à 7s 3 que j'ai pas
encore vu que je vais découvrir avec
vous et j'espère qu'il va être cool
j'espère qu'il va être cool je pense que
je vous ferai un retour en fin de vidéo
je pense qu'on laissera passer la nuit
et un peu de temps pour que je fasse un
petit peu ma conclusion dans le studio
pour vous dire ce que j'en pense et puis
et puis allez on y va c'est parti on se
balade dans peau et on teste le saunier
à 7 est roi alors
monsieur françois oui c'est moi et moi
c'est moi je vous ai amené dans ce
magnifique sac
oh la la aulas non je ne suis pas
sponsorisé par mao tech et design jérôme
si tu nous regardes lui jérôme des
bisous voila voila je vous ai amené e
dieye
je vous ai amené cette chose sauf si
ceux-ci ceci est un c'est un sosie
adjoint on vérifie on vérifie fait
remarquer tu vois assez tesla est ici
sur le dessus le mark iii
voilà arrête tu me fais rire est bon
alors je tiens j'en ai je suis un juteux
je te confie lab en échange je vais
aller m être devant la caméra là c'est
pas le même boîtier c'est pas là c'est
plus du menu assez tard quatre mois
c'est plus proche de 7 1 6 4
le petit doigt il passe le petit doigt
passe ici là et ça c'est cool parce que
sur lui là cet est roi le petit doigt il
passe pas tu vois il fait comme ça il se
baladait s'amusent ils s'amusent
ça fait un tout petit peu plus massif
ses plus gros c'est ça c'est quand même
plus c'est quand même plus gros le grip
est plus proéminente j'ai envie de dire
c'est ça c'est ça et là
là il ya un truc je le vois là parce que
parce que je ne peux pas le voir je vous
le montre ça c'est un flip screen c'est
le truc le truc qu'il fallait qu'à
steadyshot inside donc ça veut dire que
ça doit être stabilisée que ça fait de
la 4k ya pas marqué 8 k non il n'ya pas
de marquer huit cadres donc ça fait pas
de l'avicca en même temps je vais pas
dire on s'en fout parce qu'il ya des
gens qui sont concernés par la ligue
avec ses intéresse je ne me sens pas
concerné par la vie qu'a donc je m'en
fous ac tech 3 alors par contre tu vois
je suis en train de voir moi j'avais
deux boutons ici c1 c2 way et il est pas
ça et le c1 est passé ici
oui le c1 est passé et on a un gros
bouton rec qui donc signifie que c'est
quand même principalement utilisé pour à
utiliser pour la vidéo puisque les
séries à 7s sont quand même destinée à
de la vidéo les à cette ère plus à la
photo le à 7
normal c'est pour à peu près tout c'est
le truc polyvalent et la csc pour la
vidéo manu on va parler de pixels après
le savoir parce que voilà on fait juste
une petite découverte de j'aimerais que
tu l'as lu mais que tu mets ton est dans
le viseur
et moi je filme la réaction et puis
c'est impressionnant c'est
impressionnant
tu as l'impression d'avoir un même mieux
que les vieux réflexes c'est balèze par
les vieux réflexes mais j'ai fait ce que
j'ai dit j'ai mis là est dans le viseur
je fais waouh
et oui quand ça c'est ça c'est génial on
va tester le reste après c'est une belle
bestioles et la distributiun grosses
bêtes
françois tu as regardé les menus là où
maintenant mais tu m'as dit qu'il y
avait des changements il ya des petits
changements
faudrait peut-être ouais ouais t'es prêt
ou pas psychologiquement
ouais donc sony
merci juste pour le menu donc tu m'as
dit sans images par seconde yes ok on
bat k way cas de 10 bits
ouais et ça chauffe ou pas ben non ça
choque pas plus que ça parce que c'est
12 mégapixels je crois que c'est lié en
fait il ya je pense qu'ils ont ils ont
ils ont pris le parti justement de se
limiter en termes de résolution pour pas
avoir ce genre de problème
d'accord bon comment dire on s'est un
petit peu emballé dans le sens où on
s'est trouvé une table sympa on a bouffé
voilà et on a un petit peu un petit peu
zappé l'a7 et ce trois donc ce qu'on va
faire on va reprendre demain au studio
on va vous faire un petit débrief de ce
qu'on a testé on va vous montrer des
images on va faire du biros de la caméra
aussi et puis et puis voilà
et phénomène slate nous voilà donc
revenus de notre périple hier soir donc
on a fait des images en basse lumière on
a testé
moi j'ai eu la cs3 en main pendant
quelques heures donc c'est difficile de
se faire un avis très très très précis
par contre manu va sortir une vidéo
beaucoup plus détaillé que ce qu'on va
faire ici donc je vous encourage encore
une fois aller sur sa chaîne vous
abonner regardez la vidéo qui va être
d'une extrême qualité
n'empêche que on a des trucs à dire il
ya plein de choses hyper intéressant d'y
être plein de questions que vous vous
posez sûrement sur ce sony sur les specs
ce qu'on va en parler
et aussi on terminera moi je vous
donnerai mon
un petit peu ma conclusion est ce que je
vais craquer ou pas mais pour ça il
faudra rester jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo
donc déjà en terme de ce payx les
rumeurs toutes les rumeurs qu'on avait
entendu son sombre et son vrai on a de
la 4k en cas de 2 10 bits
ouais jusqu'à 120 fps en full hd ces 249
ps avec l'autofocus avec l'autofocus
pour ceux qui ont l'impression qu'on
parle chinois quand on parle de 4 2 2 10
bits machin tout ça grosso modo ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que la 7,3 il est
cadre de 0 8 bits et l'a7 est roi il est
4 2 10 bits ça veut dire tout simplement
que il ya une palette de nuances de
couleurs et aussi si j'ai bien compris
par rapport aussi de nuances de
luminance qui va être bien plus grande
donc ça veut dire que le cas de 2 10
bits à l'étalonnage on va pouvoir faire
beaucoup plus de choses qu'avec des cas
de 0,8 moi je m'en suis rendu compte
avec l'atom oc 2 et 6 où j'arrive à
sortir du cadre de 2 10 bits alors que
sur le sony je pouvais pas en termes de
couleurs le la différence est quand même
assez flagrante nous parce qu'on a pu
voir il n'y avait pas de chauffe
particulière un petit peu sur la fin du
shooting
ça va chauffer légèrement normal
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya une protection
contre ça tu sais toi pour pas que les
composants cram
c'est surtout aussi pour ne pas trop
dénaturer la colorimétrie de 14 d'une
accord c'est un capteur qui chauffe
c'est un capteur qui ne sera plus stable
en termes de colorimétrie la fameuse
colosse à jens pour avoir quelque chose
de plus proche tu me disais dfx 9
l'idée de base
pour avoir discuté avec les ingénieurs
et l'équipe des responsables produits de
chez sony c'est vraiment de pouvoir
utiliser cette caméra comme étant une
caméra b ou une caméra c'est si tu as
des autres caméras grand capteur de chez
sony à savoir la venice et life x9 donc
au niveau du boîtier
alors je vous montre de très près on est
sûr sur quelque chose d'assez familier
au final sur boîtier de 7 et 4 au niveau
des cartes hop là parce que vu que on a
du codec l'arrivée c'est pas évident
d'autres noms comme ça comme ça d'accord
au niveau des cartes vu qu'on a un codec
qui envoie du lourd quand même et des
fichiers très gros on est passé sur du
du ses fastes voilà donc ça c'est une
carte ses fastes c'est une carte 160
gigas
pour l'instant c'est le maximum qu'on
puisse avoir en termes de capacité le
principe de la carte ses fastes c'est
une carte qui va être
ils y vont dans ce boîtier là en tous
les cas il ya une rétrocompatibilité
avec les cartes sd
on n'est pas obligé d'avoir dû s'effacer
même pas forcément nécessaire à part
peut-être uniquement sur du 4 420
blessure du sd
v90 en gros on peut enregistrer tout la
plupart des codecs dans la meilleure
qualité un truc qu'on n'a pas dit non
plus c'est quelque chose que ce qu'on
attendait et alors c'est quelque chose
pour le coup je n'aime pas faire de
comparatif avec les autres marques mais
quelque chose que je trouve vachement
sens et moi un truc que j'avais trouvé
pas sans celle du tout mais t'es pas
d'accord avec moi mais c'était sur le
canon r5 le fait j'ai trouvé très bien
qu'ils ont pu se faire du rau et je
trouvais très dommage qu'on ne puisse
pas le faire en externe parce que du
coup ça a mené plein de contraintes et
je me dis que c'était peut-être plus
simple de faire dur ou en externe que de
le faire en interne la sur l'a7 3,7 s 3
on a du rau en externe via la hdmi
dureau vas-y vas-y fais monal 0 en 16
bits 1,16 vignerons en 16 bits sans que
la sortie hdmi a fait de la 4k 60fps hdr
ouais c'est ça donc c'est quand même là
pour le coup on est sur quelque chose
d'assez bon il faudra mettre un
enregistreur dessus genre atomos comme
ce qu'on est en train d'utiliser là mais
il ya la possibilité d'avoir bureau en
externe ce qui à mon sens fait beaucoup
plus de sens que le rond interne mais
bon ça c'est après c est ce qui évite
aussi de problèmes de surchauffe
bah oui puisque c'est l'enregistreur qui
va qui va qui va par qui va accuser le
coup des choses qu'on vous a montré
aussi en début de vidéo qu'on a tourné
hier le pub screen qui est juste ça
c'est vraiment génial mais on se demande
pourquoi c'était pas là avant un niveau
stabilisation il ya une double
stabilisation qui va être
c'est tellement quoi c'est tellement
courageux comme moto film et c'est ça
que je peux faire des plans en façon
clandestine comme ça si j'ai envie son
côté général sur l'appareil il ya
vraiment une sensation je trouve qu'il
ya de solidité en l'absence la qualité
perçue
ça fait ça fait plus robuste que ce qui
s'est fait jusqu'à présent était un peu
plus un tout petit peu plus massif
tu te sens en confiance avec ce soyez
plus il a un petit peu plus gros donc
j'ai pas testé le r4 ma priorité on est
plus mou avec le boîtier du arcade que
ce que c'est que les générations
précédentes il ya aussi double
stabilisation optique et numérique sur
le capteur sur le capteur donc ça c'est
c'est plutôt cool aussi ça on n'a pas eu
l'occasion de tester énormément hier je
pense que je ferai un test comparatif
voilà tu feras un petit test comparatif
la montée en iso
alors on a fait l'appareil ce sera sur
la chaîne de manu on a fait des tests
avec la sep trois exactement dans les
mêmes conditions avec la même exposition
avec la même focal pour voir un petit
peu comment s'abriter parce que tu me
disais que sony annonce un rapport
signal bruit ils ont vraiment optimisé
c'est vraiment un nouveau capteur avec
un rétroéclairage et cette nouvelle
technologie cuivre qu'avant les
composants étaient
câblés avec de l'aluminium maintenant on
est passé sur du cuivre ce qui permet
une meilleure conductivité donc du coup
tu as un rapport le fameux rapport
signal bruit de l'eau le truc qui fait
qu'on voit qu'il ya des bruits dans
l'image est nettement meilleur sur cette
nouvelle génération de capteurs c'est
vraiment ce qu'on avait quand on était à
20 25 mini zoo tu vois sur le sur la
synthèse de ce qui était déjà il ya du
bruit mais c'était gérable et là il ya
du bruit mais cga même à 400000 iso 400
maisons comme beaucoup de là le pari de
sony sait c'est ça c'est ont fait la
meilleure 4k possible qu'on puisse faire
avec la techno d'aujourd'hui dans ce
type de boîtier un autre point dont on
n'a pas parlé encore la plage dynamique
la plage dynamique 1 milliard j'étais
j'ai buggé quand tu m'a dit j'ai pris un
truc puisse commencer a ajouté j'ai dit
tiens j'ai vu que c'était un profil flat
tu vois mais j'étais sûr quel profil je
m'attendais itunes 10 à ce que tu me
dises ciné4 heslov 2 et tu m'as balancé
direct du s l'octroi quoi et le truc qui
enfin moi personnellement que j'ai
jamais réussi à gérer sur la scène 3
même le est loch 2 en interne ou en
externe par contre tu vois sur la gauche
il y vraiment cool mais en interne
s'abritent dans tous les sens c'est
ingérable et là tu m'as sortie du s
l'octroi il ya une plage dynamique de
combien menu 15e plus d'accord quand il
m le plus ça veut dire qu'on est au-delà
de 15 à fenway c'est énorme c'est ce
qu'on assure vraiment
des caméras très très haut de gamme
cinéma c'est à dire sur la génisse pour
rester chez sony sur l'alexa sur sur
certaines raid et ainsi de suite
je sais pas si on peut aller au delà et
alors pour ceux qui savent pas la plage
dynamique en gros ça va être la capacité
du capteur avoir des informations dans
les très basses lumières et dans les
hautes lumières plusieurs diaf plus on
va pouvoir aller chercher de l'info là
où ces sombres et plus on va pouvoir
aussi en garde et là où c'est trop un
clair on va passer à la dernière partie
un petit peu la conclusion savoir ce
qu'on a vraiment pensé de ce boîtier et
surtout est-ce que moi personnellement
est ce qui va m'intéresser et est-ce que
je vais l'acheter
moi ce que j'ai trouvé de super là
dessus c'est qu'on est vraiment sur une
évolution qui est net et qui est marquée
par rapport à ce qui se faisait avant
l'époque soit la synthèse 2 qui datait
vraiment ou même la 7 3 qui est hyper
répandu pour la vidéo c'est clair qu'on
est un cran au dessus les capacités
c'est vous faut six mois le fait qu'ils
aient pas de six cas où huit cas ne me
dérange pas déjà parlé dans une vidéo
qui s'affichera quelque part au dessus
maintenant est-ce que ça vaudrait le
coup de changer enfin je pense que je
suis très mal placé pour répondre à ce
genre de question parce que je vais pas
dire que le matos je m'en fous mais j'ai
pas la sensation que
une nouvelle caméra que ce soit la cs3
que ce soit le r5 ce soit et ce match je
n'ai pas la sensation que aujourd'hui
une nouvelle caméra va m'ouvrir des
possibilités créatives
le seul truc qui à la limite pourrait me
faire pencher là dessus c'est
effectivement le cas de nos 10 bits pour
aller sur une colo peut-être un peu plus
chiadé et peut-être à récupérer plus
d'infos et avoir plus de latitude sur
sur la colorimétrie mais je suis pour
l'instant assez content de ce que j'ai
donc je vais peut-être attendre un petit
peu de voir comment tous comportent si
je vais pas rien de cacher un mois à la
base je m'étais dit il sort je l'achète
il sort j'achète avant même que tu me
dises que qu'on irait le tester je
m'étais préparé le budget était même dit
si c'est dans une certaine gamme de prix
j'en prends deux donc c'est pas une
question tu vois de financière c'est qu'
il n'y a pas eu un truc mais comme une
sur toutes les caméras qui sortent
actuellement qui m'ont fait me dire ah
gratuitement ça va enfin pouvoir me
libérer quoi mais ça reste une très très
bonne caméra
je pense qu'il faut pas non plus faire
de parallèle a découvert cinq et
beaucoup de vidéos
r 5 versus à 7 est rare et où je pense
que ces deux produits qui sont
totalement différents qui s'adresse pas
du tout la même si maintenant ça moi je
le vois typiquement pour vraiment eu
voici des gens qui auraient un ascète s2
par exemple qui voudrait renouveler qui
font que l'événementiel passe pour
l'événementiel ses canons quoi pour moi
ce que je fais du mariage ou de l'es22
des choses comme ça je pense que c'est
le top du top quoi mais si on a déjà 7 3
je suis pas sûre que
ça vaille le coup greg si on a un
workflow qui marche bien si on a des
trucs qui fonctionne correctement si on
n'a pas besoin de quatre cas soit 120
fps ça peut-être tu vois ça c'est quand
même un truc j'aimerais bien que je fais
beaucoup de ralenti donc si je pouvais
avoir en 4k ça serait cool aussi
camille à 120 cm je sais c'est cool
c'est que nos m'arrête je commence à
douter la comprennent le dernier
problème et ça c'est le voilà nerf de la
guerre c'est juste la chose dont on n'a
pas parlé c'est le prix il est annoncé à
4200 euros boîtier nu et public prix
public
après les profonds récupérer la tva et
tout ça mais c'est choquant c'est chaud
parce que parce qu'ils en fassent
justement même si la comparaison se fait
pas il ya le canonnière 5 à 4500 euros
et 108 carreaux interne et tout ça est
lvs 1 h et le s âge et du coup c'est
difficile à justifier ce prêt moi je
t'avoue que je m'attendais à 1 3500
euros prêt public tu vois ce que c'était
le prix de la synthèse de je crois à sa
sortie et je m'attendais à ça je pars
attendait pas autant je pense que sony
misent sur l'iphone aussi s'il est
tellement attendu ce boîtier mais je
pense que il va falloir vraiment qu'ils
fassent un travail d'explication pour le
dire oui mais si vous voulez un boîtier
qui fait de la 4k dans tous les sens en
long en large en travers jusqu'à 120 fps
en quête de deux buts machin et c'est la
meilleure quatre cas du marché il ya
quand même plein de gens qui vont
vouloir se comparer à qui a la plus
grosse et qu'ils ont à dire ouais mais
chez canonical 2004 il ya des gens ça va
être pas ce prix pour l'instant pour moi
il est je trouve qu'il est un peu un peu
prétentieux pour moi c'est c'est un pur
bonheur dans le premier ressenti là
c'est comme si d'un seul coup sony qui a
toujours été dans une stratégie
marketing de protection de la gamme pour
éviter de cannibaliser les ventes des
modèles des caméras supérieur là il ose
dire on a fait un boîtier qui est
complémentaire à la fx 9 et à la vanille
donc c'est vraiment un outil qui va
cibler pour moi les professionnels et
pour un pro c'est pas trop cher non ça
reste une caméra qui va être avoir une
qualité d'image de ce que j'ai vu que je
trouve vraiment extraordinaire parce
qu'on n'a pas dit et pâle imitation de
temps et pas de limitation temps n'y a
pas de
on peut si tu mets des grosses cartes
quand je serai en continu tout ça pour
moi ça c'est à vraiment à prendre en
considération
si jamais vous avez envie d'acheter ce
genre de truculents qu'il ya de la
cohérence c'est bien conçu en fait du
début à la fin il est court en fait
c'est à pau mais il est cohérent
en tout cas manu je te remercie beaucoup
pour m'avoir permis d'essayer ce petit
sony parce que bas sans toi je n'aurais
pas pu et et puis en plus de cent a
passé un super bon moment donc tu
reviens quand tu veux sur la chaîne avec
avec grand plaisir
nous on espère que cette vidéo vous aura
plu d'ailleurs si c'est le cas qu'est-ce
qu'il faut tu sais ce qu'il faut faire
si la vidéo à +1 valhalla tu veux dire
les pousse tout ça ouais mais au moins
je l'espère ne vais pas inventer un coup
de main bien tu maîtrises un coup de
blasters sur le pouce en l'air qui est
situé juste en dessous de cette vidéo
pourrait bien sûr vous abonner à la
chaîne de manu le lien et en
descriptions et c'est une super bonne
chaîne et c'est un super bon gars donc
vraiment je vous recommande d'y aller et
puis allez voir aussi d'autres vidéos
que j'ai fait sur la chaîne vous vous
abonnez si c'est pas déjà le cas
et puis moi je vous dis rester curieux
et à très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo